what i've got here is something
extra special it's an rtx 3090 that can
be yours all you need to do to be
eligible is to sign up to gtc and attend
at least one session using my url which
i will put in the description but this
is not just any old rtx 3090 this is an
rtx 3090 signed by the leather jacketed
ceo and founder of nvidia jensen himself
also through some highly advanced
analysis of some of the promotional
materials that nvidia sent over for this
uh i do believe that there there's first
of all there's only one photo of jensen
actually holding one of these signed
gpus
and each signature on the box does vary
a little bit right he actually manually
signed all of them um and there's just
not that many of them to begin with but
the one that is in the photo that he's
holding up
is
i believe that exact one it matches up
perfectly so so not only do you have the
opportunity to win that signed gpu now
when you frame this on your wall you can
print out a photo of jensen actually
holding your signed gpu and actually put
that up probably frame that as well on
your wall so that's just that's super
cool so uh on to probably the most
frequently asked question on the channel
recently at least and that is where is
neural networks from scratch part 10.
and before that it was part six and
probably in the future it'll be some
other part since they seem to come out
in chunks
the deal is it's been like two years uh
just full steam ahead 100 or nearly 100
on neural networks from scratch and
the end result is in my opinion the best
content from the channel hands down the
book is incredible the videos that we've
released so far are incredible
but this took a ton of work and because
of that i had to basically not do a
whole bunch of everything else so
since the book had been complete and
definitely put out a few more neural
networks from scratch videos
i've just been wanting to get into other
stuff besides just neural networks from
scratch that's just like i said it's
been like all we've been doing and in
the meantime everything else is taking a
back seat so for example um a few of the
things that just happened to become
available and opportunities that have
arisen um are like behind me here this
camino machine an incredible machine but
if that opportunity had arisen while we
were doing the neural networks from
scratch book i could not have done it
but luckily it came up about i don't
know uh towards the end of last year
basically that this started to form and
i'm very thankful that we're able to do
a project with this but that project
that we're planning with the camino
machine
is
a massive undertaking so it's just it
requires our full attention and
especially right now primarily daniel's
attention um is kind of getting us
prepared for this so
um the the neural networks from scratch
videos take about like two weeks of our
full attention and and if not two at
least one but for sure like p10 is a is
a big one and like p10 probably 11 and
12 are all like very very big production
um going to be very challenging and also
those videos i know why you guys love
them because they take so much effort on
both of our parts and they have to be
perfect like they're the most
overproduced or not overproduced but the
most produced videos uh that that i put
out and the
the content and the subject of them is
very complex and the goal is to make it
as simple as possible without you know
glossing over and part of the problem is
because of how much time both me and
daniel have spent with neural networks
from scratch we've seen this material
like 20 plus times um it becomes very
difficult to not gloss over things so
you have to give like extra focus and
then
i i think we've done a few neural hours
from scratch videos without any single
mistake but
most of them uh for sure i would say at
least all of them have some sort of
mistake that almost gets missed and then
some of them have you know small errors
that just get missed because we've seen
this a million times
so um so just keep that in mind like i i
plan to do more neural networks from
scratch videos but
there's just so many other things that i
want to do so another thing is like
those the the quadrupeds so the little
bittle dog and stuff um i've been
wanting to get into reinforcement
learning for so long and that bittle
robot dog was like oh that's a perfect
thing to to kind of get into doing
reinforcement learning with and this
camino here i've the project that we're
going to do on that is a project that
i've been wanting to do for years and so
so i'm very happy to be able to do that
and i love you guys i love you guys for
supporting the neural networks from
scratch series in the books but you're
going to probably just be waiting a
little bit longer
but if you need the content i mean the
book does exist it's it's complete
all the content is there so uh i know
some of you guys still waiting on the
videos also have the books and like the
video is just another form i get that um
but you'll have to wait
if you don't already have the book you
can get it at nnfs.io
it's 29 for the ebook um which i
understand might still be out of range
for some of you but the the the price is
like
uh
there is no other book i i don't think
there is even another book in existence
that is like this this is not like a
intro to machine learning or a basics
with pytorch it's not that it's neural
networks from scratch and python all the
calculus everything is is being shown
short of like a master's or a phd
program i don't know where you out where
else this material exists at some point
i'm sure somebody will copy it um
but for now this is it and for it's for
29. 29. so
so uh i'd say it's a pretty good steal
and if you still can't afford 29
even though i think that's a good price
some people live in countries where the
exchange rate is just terrible and you
really shouldn't be paying like a
month's salary for the book so if you do
have a problem uh affording the ebook i
can discount that the print book it's
over 600 pages full color heavy weighted
pages um i can't discount the physical
book
they get lost in shipping and stuff
every that that price is as cheap as it
gets people ask all the time like are
there going to be like discounts for the
holidays and stuff no no never there
would never be a discount for the
holiday because that is how much that
book costs to
print ship and then account for like
loss and other issues and shipping you'd
be surprised how many neural networks
from scratch books have just
disappeared they're all attract no one
is like getting the book and then saying
i didn't get it they just disappear in
shipping
so
anyway um so that's that on the neural
network from scratch p10 i get it i know
you guys want it i love that content too
but there are other things that i also
love and that i want to work on so
besides the reinforcement learning stuff
so we got reinforcement with the biddle
reinforcement learning with the bitter
robot dog coming as well as i'm doing
reinforcement learning with starcraft 2
or at least going to try starcraft 2 is
really challenging because
you have to simplify the problem because
the you know default observation space
and the default action space of
something like starcraft 2
is
i don't even know what the number is but
probably in the millions for both so um
maybe the observation space isn't that
complex but for sure like the plausible
action space is
massive so
so um so yeah that was just a fun
challenge but
so i've got the starcraft 2 ai and
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning with biddle hopefully irl like
in real life physical
um
the camino with the project that i'm not
yet going to announce but hopefully very
soon
uh and then finally like there's so much
stuff that just never makes it to a
video even though i really wanted to do
something with it
and the two things that i want to bring
up here are neo x from a luther ai
they just recently i think it was like a
few weeks ago possibly i don't know time
is flying right now um they released neo
x which is a 20 billion parameter
transformer model which isn't nearly the
biggest it's quite large but not not
necessarily the biggest model we've ever
heard of but this is the largest
general purpose transformer model that
you can actually just go and download
the weights and biases of the model from
there you can fine-tune it for whatever
your needs are or you can just run that
model or even cooler you can like do
research on that model so we don't
really have that much really great
research on like how transformers work
what's going on as data passes through
them or even what's going on as they're
being trained very very few people have
the knowledge the expertise but also the
ability to experience um
that and so for people like
luther elia there i don't really know
how to pronounce it but for people like
that to just
this massive investment goes on goes
into it um both money and huge amounts
of time and just energy goes into this
and then they just release it um i just
think that's that's really cool uh so
definitely if you're interested in that
kind of stuff or if you're looking for
something to do like a thesis on uh
definitely check that out and then also
there is j1 and there's a few variations
but j1 jumbo is 178 billion parameters
it is not open source uh and you can't
like just download it or anything um
where but i will say even with neox i
believe not to train it because even
training it would require way more than
this but to just run inference on half
precision i believe you're going to need
one of the your i think you need like
more than 45 gigs of vram which
basically means you need one of the 48
gigabyte cards uh so i don't even think
like a single a 140 gigabyte will fit it
you will need an a6000 48 gigabytes or
you're going to need an rtx 8000 48
gigabytes so um
even that model is very tough to run but
j1 jumbo at 178 billion parameters
you're going to have even harder time
running that one anyways even if you
could download that model but aside from
just simply having like a web prompt
that you can of course use they also
have a really simple to use python api
that you can actually query this model
and there is a free tier it you'll
exhaust it pretty quickly but even the
paid stuff is pretty cheap so if you
found something that was kind of cool uh
you could you could pay for it and
i think their whole point is they're
trying to people like with these large
models are just trying to figure out
like how do we
make these models into something that
you could use in business and actually
like sell and make a profit on so
and something
similar to that is something like github
copilot where right now it is free it's
in beta or whatever but i would pay
i don't hopefully no one from github is
listening but i would pay an exorbitant
amount of money to keep using that it's
the greatest thing in the world so
so so um just no i won't pay anything
for it make sure it's free or like a
dollar a month so
so anyways um i'm excited to see what
the future holds and like i said like
even even with j1 jumbo i think there's
so much
room for um experimentation and just
analysis and research with these very
large transformer models and i promise
you there are jobs waiting for you at
the end of that tunnel because
everyone's trying to figure out like how
can we monetize this this technology
because it's like it's almost de facto
technology with a moat right there's so
few companies and people that can make
in like deploy this kind of technology
that
businesses are like frothing at the
mouth to to figure out how how can we
monetize this
so anyway um that's uh that's a
neurologist from scratch part 10 that's
some of the future content that you can
expect but also there could be totally
new things that come up uh things that
don't come out or who knows you know
like i might fail at starcraft 2
reinforcement learning or something like
that so don't hold your breath
so anyways that's all as a reminder
don't forget to sign up for gtc using
the link in the description you have to
use that link uh and then all you have
to do is sign up for that and attend at
least one uh gtc session which should
not be a problem they're at all times
like some of them are like in the middle
of the night for me or during the day
for me or there's all day long basically
from the 21st to the i want to say 24th
so you should have no problem finding a
session that you can attend and want to
attend there's topics unlike
everything so it's it's definitely a
really cool conference and it's all
online it's all free um and you have the
opportunity to win a signed 30-90 gpu
from jensen himself which is just super
cool i'm super jealous of whoever wins
that
anyways that is all for now i will see
you all in another video
you